all right let's go back to the phones at
6 1 7 8 3 0 47 50 lots of people holding
and want to see what is on people's
minds today let's go to our next caller
from the 805 area code caller from 805
tell us tell us who you are and where
you're calling from
hey this is Shane from mnsure am I on
yes you are fantastic so I had a
question for you but I also wanted to
use this brief window to elevate content
creators that are adjacent to you that I
support the folks over at hell of a way
to die podcast are veterans
giving their perspectives on veteran
issues from the left and they have not
yet found a big enough audience and
hoping that you can give them some
attention my actual question though for
you is this we've got this dialogue from
bado and other people like him about
disarmament and the thing that bothers
me is that nobody talks about disarming
law enforcement to the same level they
disarm the general population I'm very
uncomfortable with the power disparity
that a complete confiscation would
create especially with communities of
color we have gun control is typically
overwhelmingly enforced against
communities of color we saw that with
the Black Panthers it's just a
historical fact so if this disarmament
idea goes forward do you see right is
anybody having the conversation of
police disarmament to go with it well
there's a couple different things here
there's a couple different things we
have to talk about I mean number one
first of all when Beto was asked about
gun confiscation I I respected that he
said yes he's interested in that but he
didn't say total confiscation he said
there are certain weapons that he would
like to see confiscated do we agree at
least on that premise yeah okay the
second thing is so there are countries
that have it's not that they've disarmed
police but what they've done is the
average patrol officer does not carry a
firearm of firearms come out when the
equivalent of like a SWAT team or
hostage rescue team or or you know some
further
a smaller team comes out is that what
you're suggesting or are you suggesting
that just police simply should have no
not even access to firearms I think that
the police should be just disarmed to
the general level of the population
because otherwise you create an inherent
power disparity okay but I need you I
need you tell me what you mean but do
you mean that police shouldn't like okay
there are situations where if a hostage
situation gets crazy enough eventually
police come with like an armored vehicle
and a sniper rifle do you should they
not even have that as an available
resource for any situation if now let me
let me be clear I am being a bit of a
devil's advocate here I am you know I'm
a program socialist but at the same time
if we're going to go disarmament then I
do think it should be even in that
situation nobody should have those guns
not the civilians not the officers
involved I just don't trust the the
inherent power disparity that it creates
yeah I mean okay there's an interesting
philosophical discussion in there but I
think that we it's it's not a practical
one in the sense that this is not even
what's on the table I think that there
is such lower hanging fruit that we can
become activists for right now and maybe
get done that I completely respect the
the the philosophical argument that
you're having but there's no point in in
the near future where police are going
to get disarmed to the degree that
you're suggesting and I think that there
are probably five gun safety related
policies that are more likely than
police disarmament that we should all be
lobbying around right now I don't think
you're bringing up crazy things to talk
about but there are real things we can
do right away which would drastically
make our cities and streets safer I
appreciate that
Mike then my follow-up question would be
this what about the return of the
tactics of people like the Black
Panthers where they were going to
protest armed and those protests were
effective they were able to protect
themselves I've said before one of the
ways that you will get the pro-gun right
to rethink some of their ideas is if
minority groups start legally open
carrying all over the country
you are going to very quickly see some
people say hold on a second is what I'm
actually is what I'm advocating for
actually what I want yeah I've talked
about that before I'm worried about that
one though because you've got
organizations like black guns matter and
or I think it's our black rifles matter
which is you know a an African American
led organization that I do support
financially but at the same time because
they you know they teach firearm safety
but also the right tries to co-opt them
and organizations like them you know the
right is always looking for a shield
against you know accusations of racism
sexism and whatever because you know
it's so frequent so what I worry about
is is that you know when an event like
that happens what people will do is say
oh you know they're coming around our
side or some other you know completely
at right point well I don't disagree
with you I I'm I I think about this as a
thought experiment I don't actually want
anymore open carry rallies of any kind
so it's merely a thought experiment and
there is no question that there would be
groups that would co-opt those activists
no matter what listen I appreciate the
phone call I've got to move on but it is
a conversation there is no question
we're going to continue having